this is the best way to see Tubingen
from a punt a flat bottomed boat on the
river NECA hello and welcome on board
I'm Thomas and I'm steering the boat
today with a long pole
Tomas pushes the punt forwards along the
river bay
on your right is the hölderlin tower the
Swabian poet friedrich hölderlin spent
36 years of his life here sadly while
mentally ill until the 1970s only stood
fraternity's had puns it wasn't until
later that punching tours for visitors
were introduced the fraternities in Tuba
can have magnificent houses in prime
locations old university towns often
have many of these traditional student
associations the University of Tuebingen
is more than 500 years old the town is
as popular with students now as it was
in the past that's we're very happy we
have Turkish guests with us and they
like it too has a beautiful old town and
lovely lanes great cafes and charm
quotes Ave the distances are short
because everything revolves around the
university the bars and restaurants are
full of students it's a very youthful
town with a lot of greenery a perfect
place to study the university buildings
are spread around the center of Cuban
half-timbered houses abound near the
painted townhall and the square known as
the holes marked is st. George's
Collegiate Church which dates from the
15th century
hoenn tubing in Kassel rises high over
the town center part of it houses the
university's Museum of ancient cultures
which exhibits archeological artifacts
among the highlights of the collection
are stone age figures from caves in the
Swabian alb there are around 40,000
years old which makes them some of the
oldest known human artworks the
fantastic what's fantastic is that here
we have a level of artistic ability even
with these simple means a hand ax or
knife and mammoth ivory it's incredibly
hard to carve and hear an expressive
power developed that sends shivers down
my spine even as an art historian a
fantastic poem Tubingen Castle also
offers a fantastic view of the town and
the Swabian alb
you